i love it hey let me ask you lastly
before we go i shouldn't maybe this
shouldn't be the last question but
you know i worked with wes uh we did a
movie that nobody saw really called
cursed and
i just i really loved him he sent me a
letter before i worked with him and just
i still have the letter about just just
saying i love your work and i'd love for
you to
come and join us it was just but when he
passed away it broke my heart i felt
so horrible about it but i know that you
you knew him for so many years
were you guys close and did it how did
it affect you
we were close and we had mutual respect
uh
you know wes is a double threat writer
director which is you always feel
comfortable with that
and uh i did a series for wes up in
vancouver
uh and uh we were watching snl one night
i had the best department up by stanley
park because i might walk my dog in
stanley park
and we were watching snl and it was the
night of the
head wound harry sketch with dana
and uh wes and uh uh
myself my wife a couple of the actors
from the show were all sitting around
drinking a bottle of wine and headroom
harry came on
and wes is very tall you know and wes
is sitting on my couch and wes almost
fell off the couch laughing
he was laughing so hard he was crying
and he turned into
the 14 year old boy that is west loving
that dark
funny tricky humor that head wound harry
was
and uh i mean i had to like slap him on
the back because he was
he was laughing so hard he thought he
was gonna choke and
les had let down his hair so to speak in
front of me that night
gotten a little drunk you know and and
laughed until he was crying at that
sketch
and and and i think he that was kind of
my gift from wes
that he finally became one of the guys
with ball instead of just my boss you
know he was one of the guys finally
that's amazing yeah he uh i remember he
again he used to always have me do
impressions for takes and the cast was
they were just like so they had to redo
this movie curse so they redid it they
wanted him to reshoot it which he was so
pissed off about it
and uh the actors had to come back but
they recast a couple actors and
he asked me and you know it wasn't even
a huge part but i just wanted to work
with wes
i just didn't care and every day he
would just have me michael do it like
walking do it like malkovich do it like
and the cast was like tired but they
were like kind of trying to be nice but
i'm like are you sure
he's like yeah and then so i i was
barely in the movie and then when we had
a wrap party
on the video i was like 80 of it i'm a
guy that worked like six days on the
movie
and he he was just so at the end of it
we used to talk about amityville
he said it was a hoax i'm like no it
wasn't we would talk about it right up
to we're shooting and we would
just he was so fun to be around and at
the end i go
wes he goes michael i go it's great
working with you he's like
my pleasure it was a real pleasure and i
go i'm going to give you a hug now he
goes
are you sure and i go if you don't mind
he goes
okay we gave each other this nice hug
and it was just i just loved i wanted
he's one of those guys where you want
him to like you you just
you just he's such a good spirit to be
around